Oh holy crap that's amazing oh my god
that's so amazing how do you do that oh
man oh man it's not perfect but it's
amazing Hey look out for this oh look
out for this oh look out for this well
Santa look out for this Santa look out
for this Santa Santa Santa look out for
this Santa oh okay all right well oh
okay alright this seems a little bit
yes apparently there you go that's my
spleen okay all right don't know what I
was supposed to do there oh oh oh I get
it
it's part of the game besides just being
dead oh no no no no no no no this no
anything with this no no I don't want to
oh no oh no hold space for two seconds
oh he's such a mass murderer of things
always getting showered always so
adorable I have no idea what's going on
oh yay I guess Callooh Callay
please get out of here no no yes somehow
the randomness got to my son we're just
not open oi
Oh first try baby look at me I'm gonna
win
oh I didn't actually believe in myself I
should have though cuz um aye aye aye
aye aye
[Music]
devices this is my sleigh either peg
Boggs you favor
oh I can't believe how good a fun if I'm
having I'm having so many funds my funds
now I can suck my own I loaded via my
ass son I suddenly became very tired I
must rest now okay I'll just rest here
yes Wow Margot why are the chubby bunny
challenge how many marshmallows can you
fit I don't know do I have any control
over this I see some hands spilling out
of the top of my head I'm pretty sure
that's not supposed to happen
do I have just a man trapped under my
beanie at all times stated by the Mallos
am I in control here oh no oh no that is
what they always tell me I keep going
the same direction even though I'm told
not to oh all you have to do is jump I
don't think I want to that's a lot of
warning signs okay I want to tell you
personally thank you oh no problem thank
you I know depression and suicide all
too well but your videos give me hope we
hear you and support you oh oh thank you
even if I can't make happy wheel levels
this one fan and millions of others are
here I hope to talk to you again we all
love you have a great day oh thank you
okay oh and here's some death to messy
end of levels okay oh thank you it's so
adorable mmm
mark if you're reading this thanks for
everything for making me laugh on days
where that's the last thing I thought
I'd do those are probably gonna kill me
but I'm gonna read this bringing a smile
to everyone who watches your videos and
loving all of us fans almost as much as
we love you you bring us all together
with all your hilarious videos I hope
your day is going great
sincerely Evan
well thank you so much there's so much
happiness and good wheels and happy
wheels good wheels good feels good feels
good feels oh but I got the feels my
penis and spikes vitality oh okay where
am I going now is this a cannon of
happiness that's gonna take me to happy
land
[Music]
Thank You markiplier for staying with
YouTube all these years we were all
happy that you got out of the hospital
or an even more happy you play this game
by the way I'm gonna be making more
levels for you thank you so much Griffin
see Thank You everybody this is awesome
I come here for death and destruction
Monica's fields this has been happy
wheels highlights thanks for watching if
you want to see more happy wheels right
now check the description or click the
annotation for the full happy wheels
playlist and if you want to see more
happy wheels in the future please click
the like button to let me know thanks
again everyone and as always I will see
you in the next video